[Music]  an  ancient horror has awoken from its  slumber  and is hungry for blood shall we see how  many  have fallen into shadow satellite sweeps  of the war zone have uncovered what  appears to be an  underground storage facility but i  strongly suspect  where chemical weapons are hidden so we  need to move fast  to descend into the unknown alone is  or will it be a case of each man  for himself  your survival depends on the choices you  make  they will be as a compass guiding you  through the unknown  dodge greener what nightmare have these  luckless souls falling into  you keep lookout look out  look out for what one by one  their lights will be snuffed up  unless you can find the means to save  them  trapped beneath the earth swallow we  have to move let's  boy  [Music]  forever  [Applause]  you